make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are continuing our coverage
of joker war we are on part four i think
it is i think it's part four we're
continuing the joker war
so in the the last videos that we did
batman had basically been exposed to
a kind of nude version of the joker
toxin that was created
in large part through a common uh
combined effort of the joker and his new
sidekick punchline
but the nature of this joker toxin was
that it was exceedingly imp
exceedingly potent far stronger than
really any version that we'd seen before
and it was enough to put batman
in a pretty deep sleep right a pretty
deep trance at least strong enough to
allow joker to kind of make his move and
have batman off the board now harley
quinn did come to the rescue insofar as
she was able to get batman out of harm's
way but she had fed him a kind of
concoction that would help him to
overcome the serum in his body and then
bring him back right so he could kind of
go back and do his batman thing but what
this does is it starts up in the mind of
bruce wayne himself and it's almost kind
of a throwback to some old memories
right in this sense he's kind of talking
to alfred and talking about like the
nature of the batarangs in the sense
that he made him a little more
streamlined to be basically like
shurikens but simply just you know like
like ninja stars more or less but just a
different look a different design um and
it's kind of these this this interesting
scenario because it seems to be in the
early days of when they were still
working with lucious fox but before
lucious fox knew that he was batman
and so he kind of talks about how like
they might have to let lucius in on
what's going on because you'll see his
work on the streets that kind of thing
he also talks about how he has a utility
belt and he's like by the end of all
this right the bat suit's just going to
be like
one big utility belt i want to see that
i want to see like a bad suit that's
just nothing but pockets
but one of the things that alfred hits
that is that there's still a part of
batman
that believes that like he can save the
day right that he's full of optimism
right that he's desperate to believe he
can be like the perfect batman now this
is an important thing to understand
is because alfred has kind of been a
voice that bruce wayne's been hearing
ever since he was exposed to the toxin
even when he was awake and he was still
struggling the nature of hearing
alfred's voice was a way for him to kind
of focus the toxin into a singular point
to where it could still do its job
but it wouldn't really impact how he was
able to perform eventually it just
became too much right and between
fatigue
and uh and the toxin itself he ended up
kind of succumbing to it completely but
this is again
all kind of a hallucination you know
with regards to alfred and it's one of
the things that he says that you know
where batman realizes like you're not
real right you're dead
harley quinn gave me some tea to
overcome this you know alfred kind of
gives him this perspective and says like
you have a weird gift that not many
people who can affect
change have which is to say you're able
to use this moment to kind of survey
what's what you know what's going on in
your city from a bird's eye view now it
doesn't mean literally it simply means
that this is granting batman a reprieve
it gives him a chance to kind of look at
the bigger picture see everything that's
happening and decide what his worth
is with you know with the city of gotham
the various heroes who were there
all that kind of stuff and so while he's
unconscious of course harley quinn
tending to him is suddenly met by the
arrival of punchline using
this as as kind of a chance to basically
take out bruce wayne right to take out
harley and to take out bruce wayne and
so with that being the case we sit back
down with batman and alfred and and the
funny thing is that the whole scenario
with harley quinn and punchline is
actually going to become a little bit of
a background thing here
it'll be relatively even but i think the
main brunt of this is really bruce wayne
himself and alfred fixes us some some
tea right he says if we're gonna have
tea
we're gonna do it properly right and so
he basically makes him a darjeeling
blend and this is this is a tea that
alfred served to bruce wayne whenever he
was stressed whenever he was frightened
whenever he was the most disturbed from
a case that he was working on this
seemed to be especially important
during the early days of the joker
because the joker's crimes were so
heinous
and the significance of this tea as it's
explained here is that it was alfred's
way of telling batman everything's gonna
be okay
the bruce wayne was too stubborn and and
really he
made himself too hard of a person in a
lot of ways to really accept alfred
coming to him putting his hand on his
shoulder and saying everything's gonna
be okay master bruce and bruce wayne
accepting it and saying yeah you know
and being comforted by it he was on the
inside he just wouldn't really allow
himself to show it and so alfred
wouldn't really tell him everything was
gonna be okay in so many words
instead he would make him this t and it
was a kind of unspoken conversation
between the two which is cool because
it's designed to show the closeness
between alfred and bruce right alfred
was a father figure you know in in a lot
of ways in almost every important way
and so you know
he kind of asks bruce wayne like tell me
what's happening like tell me how bad is
all of this
and the response of batman is the
joker's using all of his money to tie up
the legal system to keep joker's gangs
on the streets he's terrorizing people
he's he's literally taking people out
but he's taken the entire family fortune
the wayne manor wayne enterprises he had
lucian fox basically modified vehicles
into into deadly contraptions and so on
right like he's essentially conquered
gotham and all of it's been paid for by
the wayne foundation so the bruce wayne
foundation or really just the wayne
foundation itself which was designed
and and serves the purpose of protecting
and making gotham a better place
is now being used to tear it to the
ground and it's an important thing
because
alfred kind of comments like you've seen
this from the beginning right you know
the nature of the joker from the
beginning the nature of the joker is
he's he's cold he's disconnected right
he mocks
everything that people love he mocks
family he mocks relationships all that
kind of stuff and he pulls his allies
closest to him as a mockery of that
right you have the you have
you have robin he's got harley quinn and
harley quinn is designed to be a mockery
right you treat robin as a kind of son
dick grayson was a surrogate son tim
drake jason todd damien wayne was a
biological son but you see your robins
as
as children and you take care of them
that way you make sure that they become
strong capable you raise them to become
productive members of society you teach
them right from wrong if they don't know
this is the kind of role that you play
joker abuses his sidekicks right he
treats them terribly he
makes life rough for them he puts them
in situations that could very well cost
them their lives he's a mockery to
everything that you believe
but there's one massive difference
between you and him
for the joker taking one life is no
different than taking a million
if it means he can get to you but this
is different for you you value the
sanctity of life
you understand the importance of family
and friends these things are relevant to
you
and so you end up switching back to
harley and punchline and the fight
between these two is pretty
straightforward right punchline's got
like a flamethrower she's just like you
know torching this whole place and
harley quinn's like shooting the place
up right and and for the most part it's
kind of round two but there is a cool
discussion here between these two
characters
harley quinn sees punchline as kind of a
in a continuation of herself
right in the sense that there's a little
bit of a conversation that goes on you
know when you have punchline kind of you
know fighting against harley she makes a
comment about the nature of harley right
that harley thinks she's somebody
special that she thinks she was somebody
unique but she's not that in the end
like the story of harley is just kind of
this this
boring mundane uninspiring story right
like harley quinn was she was this young
girl you know who thought she was
destined to do something great with her
life you know and then she wanted to do
something great for people she wanted to
help people and so on and so she ended
up getting a job working in arkham
asylum and she met the joker and the
joker swindled her he tricked her he
convinced her he was a sensitive guy she
got caught up in the whole thing she
ended up becoming a sidekick
and then basically ended up leaving
right you know what she kind of tells
harley is like you're a basic becky
there's nothing interesting about you
right you're not intriguing you're just
some girl who got her heart broken by a
crazy guy and now that you left you
think you're somehow
cut from a different cloth like no
you're you're basic there's nothing
intriguing about you she's like i
on the other hand i saw the world for
what it was right the world was going
crazy and people were pretending like it
wasn't the world was falling apart
it was going to pieces and people were
just kind of looking around and saying
no everything's okay
as if they said it enough times it would
be true and then she heard the joker
speak she heard him talk
she heard this this guy who was talking
about how like the world is crazy and
the world was was nuts you know and the
only way to survive it was to be as
insane as he was that he
in a lot of ways kind of offered this
this vocalized
speech on how punchlines saw the world
and she found herself enamored with it
the funny thing about this is
that is the story of harley quinn that's
the thing that's what punchline doesn't
grasp her story
is the story of harley quinn right it's
being caught up by a different means
but it's being caught up nonetheless she
thinks she's special when she's not and
that's what harley tries to tell her
like i thought the joker had a heart do
you think he has a brain but at the end
of the day
everybody's a means to an end right like
the joker doesn't care about anybody but
himself and batman that's it that's the
only thing he cares about he doesn't
care about who he has to hurt who he has
to sacrifice who he has to put in harm's
way
as long as it gets him to the bat what
you haven't figured out is that you're
not special
right like you think you are but you're
not you believe that you can change him
or you believe that somehow you're
special in this this unique way to where
only you can truly understand him like
you're literally just a victim like
you've got a victim complex but at some
point in time you're gonna come to an
understanding of your place in the world
you're gonna realize you're not as
special as you think you are and that's
that's kind of a crazy thing because it
almost seems like what harley quinn says
impacts punchline and she thinks it's
true because she's like you believe
you're wrong and i'll prove you're wrong
right like i'll show you what the joker
really believes once i kill batman
myself and that's her mistake right
that's that's the obvious instance that
she doesn't truly understand the joker
because if she did she would know that
the joker's
joker doesn't want to kill batman right
like that's not the whole idea that
joker loves the cat and mouse game he
loves the idea of batman chasing him
that's that's what he digs right
that that's his whole stick and so if
she kills batman the joker's probably
gonna kill her just out of wrath just
out of anger
and so you switch back to alfred you
switch back to bruce wayne and one of
the things alfred says here
this is probably one of the most amazing
conversations one of the most amazing
things that alpha brings up right he
says you take yourself too seriously
master bruce right but batman is a
child's dream
you can travel the world and learn every
possible way to save everybody that's a
child's perception only a child would
look at that and think that it's
actually possible but once you get out
into the real world once you learn the
the limitations of humanity you realize
that you can't
do it on your own but the dream is still
possible in the sense that yes you can
save everybody you just need the help of
others to do it and he says like you
you've spent too much time
trying to save my life because you won't
accept that i'm dead you've pushed away
the people that remind you of that fact
you hold it against damian wayne right
demian wayne was the one who went into
gotham during the city of bane and
and was despite being told if the bat
family enters here i will kill alfred
damien was the one who believed that he
could say alfred he went into the city
he basically broke the truce that led to
to damien wayne once he was captured
seeing alfred killed right in front of
him batman holds it against damien
saying like if you hadn't gone into
gotham then he never would have died you
hold it against dick grayson because he
was shot in the head so he
became rick grace in one of the worst
story arcs ever but like he became
somebody who wasn't
wasn't dick grayson he wasn't his normal
self you held it against selena for
making you feel like it was never safe
for you to come home that you you felt
like you couldn't really trust anybody
you hold it against
everybody else but the reality and this
is what bruce wayne kind of accepts he
says like i failed and that's when
alfred just freaks out and slaps him
across the face and he's like the
story's not over man like
you're batman right you have to accept
the world that you that you live in and
you
have to accept what you can control
there are things in gotham that you
can't control you can't make people be
good guys
you can't make people do things
differently the only thing you can
control is how you operate as batman how
you inspire people but some things are
beyond your ability to control here
you have to accept that you did not and
you cannot save me
you were in a place where you couldn't
get to me you didn't know
what damian did you didn't know that i
was being held by bane and you didn't
know that he was going to kill me so you
can't hold yourself for that
you can't say like it's my fault that
alfred died you didn't know what could
you have possibly done right you did not
and you cannot save your parents
you were a little kid you didn't know
that leaving the theater and your father
taking that shortcut would lead to them
being killed but even if you tried what
could you have possibly done
in the face of a gun at 12 years old
like you you have to stop holding
yourself accountable for these things
right you can't hold
all these things against yourself
there's nothing you could have done but
you can
save yourself and in doing so you can
save the lives of so many other people
in this city that you love so much and
he says that's what's important every
life that you save
is a victory against death against the
joker if you truly want to defeat the
joker if you truly want to beat him then
be the opposite of what the joker stands
for if the joker is deaf
be life if the joker is chaos be order
be these things
be be what matters most in this world
and so he tells him right like
wake up you know where batman says like
i don't know if i can do this without
you the response of alfred is
i'm always here you've known me your
entire life
you don't need me on the other side of a
microphone to know what i would tell you
you don't need to hear me tell you that
you're doing a great job you don't need
to hear me tell you that i'm proud of
you you know that because you know me
and you know what would make me proud
what would make me proud is seeing you
go forward
live your life save yourself and make
something of the city of gotham batman
snaps up right immediately wakes up as
soon as punchline gets to him
let me tell you something man this was a
girl that was getting a little big for
her britches
right like she thought she could take on
batman you serious
not a chance right like batman wakes up
and he's like okay so
like uh this this we're playing a
different game now this toxin that was
in my system is gone now right this
toxin is totally out of me and i'm right
back to 100 again if you want to do this
dance
girl we can do this dance but understand
i've done this dance with a lot of
people
right and it's like bane said from the
dark knight returns like shipwrecked men
turning to seawater due to
uncontrollable thirst
many have died trying
and so punchline gets subdued pretty
quickly right and then after that it's
like okay
let's take care of this and so he's like
i need to reactivate my communication
systems well the problem with this is
that he fried his circuits back when he
was at the theater and then of course we
get the most batman response ever don't
underestimate what i can fit in this
belt and then he's like i called the
battery right this is kind of like a
backup system and he basically
and harley quinn's just like no come on
man you know it's like
it's like computer right this is batman
get me the location of the family and
it's like which family members do you
want and he's like i need everybody
cue to catwoman right catwoman's like i
gotta go i gotta bounce right so she's
part of the bat family she gets the
message from batman that bruce wayne is
back
she goes to leave the the hotel right
the the club of the penguin right this
kind of places on lockdown while they
ride out the whole joker attack and
she's like you guys need to come with me
and they're like why would we leave in
the midst of a joker attack right i mean
it's one of these cool things where it's
like everybody knows how dangerous the
joker is and she's like what if i told
you that i can make you and edward
enigma billionaires if you guys come
with me
the sound of money most people will buy
into that sound so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end
if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you
drop a like and i will catch you all
later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you